clemmy is with us clemmy is in uh
atlanta georgia is it clemmy is that
correct
yes sorry how can we help hey how you
doing fellas
hey so i've got a question i'm in a job
um that i love
and with my career trajectory i plan on
i'm assistant manager at the retail
store
and within the next year or so i'm going
to bump up to a
store manager and write that out for
another five years
and stay with the company and go to um
corporate office after that
but my quandary is that i have
credit card quoted to me and it goes
against everything that i believe
in and i have to push these get stored
credit cards
and i'm having a hard time um
doing my job effectively and also and
also i don't want that to um hinder me
from moving up within my company so i'm
at a loss of what to do in this regard
how long have you been with him
uh since 2016. so i'm going on five
years
what do you make i'm almost 60.
how big a knot is in your stomach
well listening to you every day doesn't
help
[Laughter]
sorry about that brother so i'm really
pushing something i don't believe in him
let me listen brother my friend i
crossed that same path
and here's the reality it is truly a
matter of you
coming to understand that the skill set
that you've been blessed to have
the way that you work the way that you
serve customer service and sales
that same skill set can be used
elsewhere
without you having to have a conflict of
what you believe in
and it's going to require you to have
that thought process
before you gain clarity and i would tell
you what i did was i started to write
down
options where where else can i go
and help people and serve well without
having to do something i don't believe
in
and i'm going to tell you in that
industry it's not going to go away
you're not going to be able to miss this
in order to move up you're going to have
to embrace it and
and not only embrace it do it well so
that's where you're going to have that
crisis of kind of internal conflict
you're going to have to change
industries but that doesn't mean you
can't still can't serve people
now here two or three things come to
mind one is you've got a detailed
career path laid out in your mind with
this company
so you're not abandoning a 60 000 your
job that you hate
no you're abandoning a dream that you've
had yeah
yeah if you leave this company and
that's going to be very hard to do
that's why this conflict is so real and
i'm not suggesting that you
have to do this on principle you're
calling and saying
that the principles are that you feel
like you're in conflict
so one thing is i think you need to it's
going to take you a little while
and you don't have to panic and you're
not stealing from you're not stealing
bubble gum from little children i mean
this is not
you know you're not you know you're just
doing something that you don't feel
good about that you wouldn't do for your
own kids you wouldn't do for your mama
and you know so you're violating your
conscience in that regard
and so but but it's not you're not
you're not doing anything illegal and
you're not doing anything immoral
uh so i would take my time and
work my way into a new dream
a new career path that uh that i can
begin working on and
so you know embrace some of ken
coleman's materials at kingcoleman.com
and you know the proximity principle
book will give you a copy i'll have
madison pick up and give you a copy
so that's kind of thing one is there's a
real
emotional process that probably is going
to take more than 10 minutes
okay if they came in and said you had to
do something illegal
that would take you about a minute and a
half to walk out the door
right absolutely but but this is not
this is not that situation this is just
a
this is a rub is what this is but it's a
rub that's
like chris said it's not going away now
the second thing is
to embrace what chris's portion of
advice was
one of my favorite books on business
that i've ever read is by our friend
rabbi daniel lapin and it's called thou
shall prosper
and rabbi lapin as you can obviously
guess is a jewish orthodox rabbi
and the book is the 10 reasons that
jewish people have had a tendency to
prosper
throughout history beyond the population
that they've been installed in
and so for instance three percent of
americans are jewish 67 percent of the
forbes 400
is so these are 10 principles we all
want to know
right those of us that aren't jewish but
rabbi and i have become really good
friends over the years and one of the 10
principles
is that over a long period of time
it is almost impossible for someone to
prosper
doing something that they don't believe
to be morally correct yes
so it's going to be very difficult over
the next 10 years
for your dream path to actually occur
because you have this other you know
knot
in your stomach and you know and i'm
sorry i put it there but i'm
glad you recognized it i mean i i again
i'm not pounding my fist and
yelling that this company is horrible or
something they're just a retail company
selling credit cards they all do
my goal is that one day enough americans
wake up and realize
that the credit card is basically the
cigarette of the financial world
that companies like this quit doing that
because the
public pressure forces them to like the
public pressure is forced to change in
smoking you know when i was growing up
you could smoke on an airplane
a metal tube with people in it full of
smoke i mean it's just amazing in the
air
it's just and the funniest one was when
they went to no smoking sections
yes as if as if as if the magic you were
exhausted it's like the no p
into the pool i mean you know it's like
it doesn't go to the other end of the
pool come on
and so um you know but anyway that you
know that's what's going to happen if as
we continue to have more and more and
more people understand
that living debt-free is a fabulous way
of doing it
it really is and clemie i'm going to
tell you that little knot that you have
right now is only going to continue to
grow
so i i am too but i'm excited for you
the thing that that
i got to was that it was a matter of the
lord had something else for me to do
and so having that awareness as dave
said you do shift the dream
but you do understand that you're still
able to serve people and use the skill
set you've been
blessed to have and that you've polished
and so again
get ken's book we're going to send you a
copy i want you to read it but start to
lay out options
and i'm proud of you for reaching out
and talking about this
uh early on it was something i struggled
with before i reached out to a mentor to
discuss
yeah i think the options is a big deal
when you've got a new
dream that is as detailed as your
current dream oh man
oh game changer in a different area
that's not going to cause you these
knots in your stomach yeah
then making the change will be easy
right now the idea of making the change
is going from this
dialed in path to nothing yep and that's
not a jump anybody can make emotionally
if you're wise
your emotions will stop you from doing
that and they should so take your
time and let's get a new dream detailed
out
a new path that says i'm going to work
here and then i'm going to be a store
manager and then i'm going to be
original manager and then i'm going to
work in the home office and whatever it
is i mean that you had it
laid out i mean you got it dialed in and
uh but i
i wish i could tell you that the big box
whatever it is uh retailer home depot
they'll wake up uh lowe's uh whoever it
is you know
walmart whoever it is i don't know who
it is that i wish i could tell you they
were going to quit peddling credit cards
soon enough for your dream to come true
but they're not nope they're not
um targeted we're gonna keep working on
them at ramsey though yeah we are
until we bother them enough that enough
people start to realize that i think we
can change create a whole movement i
think we are
we are we are going to create